aber ich bin froh dass wir in unserem
land noch mama und papa sagen dürfen in
anderen ländern wird darüber diskutiert
ob man das schafft dass man noch ein
papa sagt ja also da bin ich froh dass
wir darüber noch reden können aber im
endeffekt sollte das keine geschlechter
fahrer sein soll dass seite einfach da
nachgeben was jemand kann die container
spielen dann soll sich das spielen und
wenn sie damit erfolg hat dann ist das
etwas tolles und wenn sie sehr natürlich
selber sagt sich immer als mama denn
vielleicht auch selber immer gesagt hat
dann wird das vielleicht damit zusammen
hängen aber eigentlich sollte man sich
immer den menschen angucken und nicht
das geschlecht wenn das ist glaube ich
das entscheiden und wenn wir sehen dass
zwar leider aus meiner arbeit auch immer
wieder dass ich merke dass das war nach
außen demonstriert wird aber erst noch
lange nicht da ist dass wir wirklich
eine absolute gleichberechtigung haben
es ist leider noch viel viel viel viel
viel zu tun um das zu erreichen da
können wir konnten machen und und langer
weg ist ein langer weg aber wir sind ja
auf dem weg dahin ich hoffe bloß dass
wir uns auf dem weg dahin nicht mit
vielen vielen dingen verlieren unsere
gesellschaft
[Musik]